what's going on guys here's a question
for you got any plans Sunday night I
know what I'm doing I'm gonna watch a
little Game of Thrones and I know the
three people sitting around this table
are gonna be watching it as well
got a Hodor you go you got a Searcy and
you have a Michelle boy - Roth Cornett
and a Spencer Gilbert what's going on
you guys these are our hosts of watching
Thrones our weekly Game of Thrones recap
and just theory
just boiler room you guys are just gonna
be like hunkering down and figuring it
out there's a lot of Game of Thrones
recap shows alien on the internet but
ours is also one of them small council
you know what I think this game of
Thrones recap show sits on the Iron
Throne of Game of Thrones recap shows
reference so we are the Brotherhood with
all the banners oh yeah by the way
without all the banners right here so
fandom put up a poll asking everybody
who's gonna be sitting on the Iron
Throne at the end and I'm sure you guys
all got to see the results got to see
the tabulations thoughts are they way
off Michelle let's start with you and
just go around the horn and hear some
thoughts I mean are we talking about the
actual results now we can say like who
won the poll and who it was like kind of
2nd and 3rd I think it's out there going
there I go there I would say there there
are pretty obvious results I would say
you know the winner right at the top Jon
Snow it's it's it's the obvious choice
which is exactly why I don't think it's
gonna be the real one it's a little -
Lord of the Rings it's a little too out
there it's a little too like ultimate
last hero and George has done nothing
but promised us heartache and
bittersweet endings so I no I don't
think it's gonna be that easy at all
yeah he's definitely a fan favorite and
second on the list here is Daenerys
Targaryen so do we think there's any way
they do that kind of fanservice no not
even remotely it's not gonna be either I
think that the one that stands the best
chance and I still agree it's not gonna
be Jon Snow is Jon Snow because if you
look about if you look at the the books
in their origin the idea of a song
nice fire and ice in every conceivable
way in terms of his parentage as we now
know he is both living and dead he is
the combination the the kind of
paradoxical culmination of everything
that this world is about but it's still
not gonna be him and to your point
Michelle what george RR martin has
promised us ultimately is to be left
wanting more and unsatisfied cuz he's
never gonna finish this books but even
if the original intent with the first
three books was to break the tropes by
having it be a bastard son having it be
a girl who had been once sold into
marriage having it be a dwarf that are
the heroes of the tale now Benioff and
Weiss are way too hip to the skip that
now we are anticipating that there's
just no way it's going to be that no one
sits on that throne in the end I hate to
quibble with you guys but I think that
we are going to while we all expect the
twist the twist is that there will be no
twist or rather do you think that this
show when I fell in love with it was
what you're saying is John and Danny
both baby like they're gonna get my
super traditional
this show started out with the
subversion of these things like I said
the bastards the dwarves that them it
was following their story but we're
learning that they're not who we thought
they were there actually the Highborne
royalty and they're gonna fulfill the
prophecy and save the land is my biggest
bone to pick in the latest season to the
show and I'm sorry but it seems like
it's heading there this used to be a
gritty grounded show and now it's
Dungeons and Dragons Azure you're high
sir fantastic but second it's not game
it's I don't believe that I really am in
Michelle Wayne because I really I have a
theory about where it is going but I
certainly think and we've heard hints
that Daenerys wildy there betray John
first of all there's a betrayal promised
to her we don't know where that's coming
from her if it will be fulfilled but I
think that we are gonna see either a
massive heel turn or we're gonna see her
extremely humbled because she's going to
make a mistake because if anything that
the show is about is about the frailty
of human nature and she is set up so
well at this point she's going to make a
mistake and it is gonna cost her
everything for sure you mean besides
boning her nephew you guys have missed
the entire point of Dragon Soul is OK
with insects yeah baby steps the use of
Michelle boy are not the views
random screen junkies hormones pretty
successful for John and Danny's baby now
it is Circe's pregnant nothing's gonna
come out with we can dive into that or I
honestly do want to hear what Roth's
theory is about where it is going
because I think we've talked a little
bit about like where we think it's not
going yeah Broadway the happy ending so
wouldn't what's your theory you said
something earlier you see no one no no
if you look at the vision and you look
at the throne room
there's snow coming down everything is
decimated if you look at what Daenerys
has even said that she wants to do if
you break the we break the wheel you
don't break the wheel by reinstating a
new monarchy at all and if you look at
who's coming from the north yes it's
it's it's the White Walkers yes it's
it's the knight king but it's who is
defending who's coming to further south
than they've ever been as well can if
the living make it at all if this isn't
just kind of like a time as a flat
circle and it's the reset of the wheel
whatever I'm a McConaughey somehow comes
in it's a thing it's just a long prequel
to the next true detective I think I
should be clear that that's not what I'm
proposing it's not that and there are
survivors if you think about who's
coming south with them it's the free
folk and the free folk have an entirely
different system of government right
they do not operate the way that the
Westeros used it's kind of echoing in
Mereen when they like kill the Masters
you're free and then like what do we do
so it's gonna be like teaching direct
democracy to feudal peasant what do you
think she's gonna rule with like a
republic or a full I Danny's gonna rule
at all I don't know she survives okay I
don't think it's that clean because I
don't think anything about this show is
that clean just think the whole world is
gonna burn it
one's gonna be dead I don't think that
necessarily either that's that's one
theory that everything just ends and
we've been ignoring the real problem and
then it's just this big metaphor for
ignoring the real problem in the world
and getting too caught up in your petty
concerns and then you all burn for it
but I don't know that it'll be that I'm
saying that that we're talking about
actual breaking the wheel one of the
things that I think this show does so
well is fulfill exactly what the
characters want but poetically in a way
that they wouldn't think they wanted
Sansa wanted to get married while she's
been married twice how did that work out
Aria want it to be a boy and she wanted
to live in freedom now she did John
wanted to be legitimate you are and it's
not gonna be easy you know what you wish
for yeah careful what you wish for Ron
would Rob wanted to be like his dad so
Daenerys might get what she wants but
it's not gonna be in the way that she
was no there's just that's actually
feeds into how I've been thinking about
the end of it all because there's this
really big prophecy that this whole show
has kind of revolved around with this
prince that was promised and there's a
lot of speculation and there's a lot of
theory about what that exactly means
like is that John is that the princess
who was promised they made a point of
that last season with the gender noun
with high Valyrian like is it actually
Danny
it's Davos right sorry we all agree it's
Davos yeah absolutely azor Ahai totally
happy I'm going with Jamie but we're we
can stick for the house or our yeah yeah
or Gendry or pod
it's pod you guys pod is the prince that
was promised but there's a whole we're
really not talking about actually the
big threat of this season which is the
White Walkers and what's actually gonna
happen in that battle and there's a
really big theory going around about
this prince that was promised and one of
the reasons the White Walkers is
actually even coming down and scaled the
wall is because they want this prince
that was promised that there's actually
a possibility that the whole reason that
they haven't come down in the first
place was the truce during the last long
night where possibly it became all about
those babies that they turned into the
White Walkers I thought I saw a really
cool theory that basically says John is
going to be the prince that was promised
that might actually become the next
night
okay so he's looking for a replacement
I'm sure that would be really cool
because then you've got the sacrifice
that Danny has to make there might be a
whole way where like he saves all it
says really for the prop for the
prophecy is that like he's gonna save
the world from darkness what if he does
that by becoming the next night King and
heading back up to the wall it's sort of
that's leaning more heavily on like book
stuff and real deep knowledge I think if
they break out too much Prince who was
promised on the show did it well
Melisandre did it can vara did it back
in Essos Aemon Targaryen talked about it
as far he was saying it was gonna be
Danny everything waking the stone dragon
but like the prince that was promised in
his aura hi it's been going on since I
believe season 2 when Melisandre first
started talking about it it's just been
this recurring thread and it's huge in
the books obviously but they haven't
ignored it in the show at all it seems
like Roth and Michelle are both leaning
towards oh they are not going to give
you the happy ending because that's not
what they do
it's messy and it doesn't come to
fruition but Spencer last season it
became there was a little more
fanservice and it was a little more
streamlined the journey and you think
it's gonna continue on that path yeah I
mean unless my kids tell if it's because
of like this has been so over analysed
and there's such a rabid fan hood about
this that we've like dug into all the
signs and all the clues in a way that
maybe george RR martin didn't think we
went or been alpha noise didn't think we
would bother to so we predicted
everything and they haven't paying
attention yeah but this was written long
ago and that does I do think there's one
arrow left in his quiver because I just
remember a some interview with Benioff
and Weiss talking about the three I'm
gonna swear holy [ __ ] moments when they
read his outline one of them was Stannis
burning Shirin one of them was the
reveal of Hodor and why he can say that
and then they said that there's one more
moment that is at the very end of the
series that gave them that holy [ __ ]
feeling so we have yet to see that and I
so they clearly have one more big twist
left and you don't think it was the
reveal of John being our plus l equals J
come on the big reveal I was just
curious okay
was in theory a pretty big moment for
people who weren't spoiled and didn't
know anything about it the fact he's
actually a legitimate heir to the throne
yeah and and what that's gonna mean for
his relationship for his aunt lover is
gonna be very complicated going forward
but I there is one person that a lot of
people think is going to sit on the
throne and it's Sansa that and that
would go along with what I was saying
that Sansa wanted to be queen right
and the path there was much harder and
much darker than she thought it would
have been she's talked about learning a
lot from Cersei she certainly has
political acumen she likes leading at
Winterfell ari has got her back it seems
at this point what do you think that I
think we can see a villain turn from
Santa and perhaps Arya they've had the
requisite amount of trauma to turn into
some true sociopaths which is what it
takes you know when you have mentors
like Littlefinger and Ramsay Bolton you
kind of end up gaining power in some
pretty effed up ways so I can see us
some of the Starks kind of splitting off
from the rest of the crew here's a
question just as a fan I'm wondering if
you couldn't like me a little bit how
much collaboration is there between
george RR martin and Weiss and Benioff
and they were kind of given bullet
points datings right and that it's kind
of been left up to them how they
interpret those bullet points and how
they get there and actually I would love
to talk to you guys about because I
don't know how much of a reward I'll
watch but like what things in past
episodes that you might have missed when
you were watching it the first time or
like things that you kind of see
differently because I think that like as
far as how the Benioff and Weiss have
interpreted it there's definitely been
some differences between those in the
books and like how much more are they
gonna spin off the reservation well also
to go back on that point just even
earlier as far as outlines from george
RR martin goes they published his
original outline pitch for the whole
series to his publisher Sansa villain
yeah she breaks bad granted plenty of
things have changed john has a love
triangle with Arya and Tyrion so
changes that change is that the love
triangle now went to dinner yes
anterior the love triangles about Tyrion
but enough other things he deviated from
in that original outline but Sansa I
mean that's a meta point but could be
that's another heel turn yeah yeah I
mean it is a heel turn or is it a
justified reaction to what she's been
through like she she always lands on her
feet she's proved herself a survivor but
maybe yeah it's the wiring good portion
of last season earning the trust back
between her and Aria yeah like to just
go ahead and break that again would be
really unsatisfied
oh okay yeah you're not being total
morons anymore do like from a certain
point of view however from a certain you
know she says two things that I think
are supporting your theory which is she
says I learned quite a lot from Cersei
and then she said thank you Littlefinger
for teaching me these lessons I'll never
forget them
and I feel like that backs up the theory
that she's gonna take what she learned
from these two and say essentially like
you're never gonna f with my family
again I don't think she'll he'll turn
against her sister as long as her sister
has her back but she might become quite
worthless and necessarily so the pack
survives yeah she's found her pack again
yeah that's how I kind of comic that
whole thing I haven't heard a lot of
Searcy talk from you guys so what are
the chances cuz she is conniving she she
is a survivor and she had huge
machinations last year and ended up
wiping out all of her foes in King's
Landing so what are her chances of
ending up I mean she's wiped out all of
her foes but she's also wiped out all of
her friends you know yeah he's like
she's she's left the hood everyone
around her is like a hanger-on it's like
just trying to get her money I don't
trust
I really love with the young she's
relying too much on hired help and like
this weird year on guy the sexy pirate
that don't get involved with a sexy
pirate is nothing but trouble always get
involved with the sexy pirate I mean she
doesn't she has gold but it's on credit
she's got credit that she's used to hire
an army but that can disappear pretty
quick it's hard to say because part of
her prophecy right is that a younger
more beautiful Queen is gonna to take
her place and everybody was like well
that was Marjorie but it was it or is it
one of these other two contenders that
could come in and take her place yeah
yeah Daenerys or Sansa I think the
better contender and the obvious one is
Daenerys but we don't know that for sure
and then we also have the valonqar
prophecy of how she's going to bite it
yeah the little brother bro yeah the
little brother wrapping his hands around
her throat and choking the life from her
yeah sure what about it could be Jamie
Jamie it's not too obvious could be
Jamie or could be the guy who drinks and
knows things that it could be arya
bacterium ass what's Tyrians path to the
throne okay he wants to be the hand i
think he wants to be the guy behind the
girl or the guy although if Cersei and
Jaime Danny if Cersei and Jaime die
isn't it he's bi right now it's kind of
a whole strongest winds the day sort of
thing
that's why Robert won and in the first
place yeah I mean you're saying because
he's in Lannister now a lannister sits
on the throne yeah I mean she's just
kind of been like screw you know like
I'm telling you
I got no right to it and so the only one
that actually technically has a claim
two people that have a claim are Gendry
and John depending on who you wouldn't
you would more than anyone else they
have an actual according to the rules
I'm not saying like they technically
Gendry doesn't unless he's voted by a
king or a queen and why would you do
that because then it's the Blackfyre
rebellion is all over again and you know
what we only have six more freaking
episodes yeah exactly the only reason to
legitimize him would be to make as a
political move because you wanted Gendry
there for some reason I mean I know why
I want Gendry there but that's just me
yeah I think if you're high weather
again let's go poor John where there's
this moment I remember what thinking
about things we remember where Daenerys
they're just sort of looking over the
ocean together and slowly falling in
love with the relative and about Tyrion
you know he says he's a good talker and
she says well people are usually like
like what they're good at you know and
and John just morose boy than he is says
not me and so what are the things that
he's good at he's good at fighting he's
good at leading he doesn't want brooding
caves caves caving I can come back he
doesn't want any of this not what he'll
do it but he doesn't want it so you're
saying that's Tyrion as well wouldn't
want forward yeah yeah and you're
speaking to like the the kind of poetry
of the people of people's character arcs
of getting what they either don't want
or what they didn't realize they want I
think that Tyrians future is in the
North particularly with the Nights Watch
maybe because if he starts as like the
whoring you know throwing his money
around doesn't care no sense of duty to
somebody who's maybe the thousandth
Commander of the Nights Watch who would
be the next one after dolorous EDD who's
at the top of my death pool live with a
name like that doing like big
predictions I this this is a good this
is a good segue because I want smaller
predictions I want okay who do you think
is gonna die first ooh that's cool I
think it's gonna be big is gonna like be
character but so you think it's mean a
big one
I think out of the gate they're gonna
sucker punch
all of us when a notable death I
wooden I would I would hate to wager
incorrectly on this and say it's Danny
right away I definitely think she yeah I
think it's gonna be I don't necessarily
think it's that but I think it'll be
unheard of your first gem II or someone
big is going to die immediately I think
they're just gonna not cover
Theon's story anymore and just see if
anyone notices oh I think yeah like
genuinely I think that he's he's
suffered enough if they are listening to
fans it's not the most popular
storylines the Iron Islands I think are
so miserable even by Game of Thrones
standards to just like pan out of his
dead body unlike a salty rock and then
never speak of it again this was a good
first step and we haven't talked a ton
about the night King what are the
chances that he sits on that big old
chair how do you keep the chair yeah
sleep there's so much we don't know yeah
I was a dance party and invites everyone
do you feel like this is a potential end
that it's just they win a nuclear winter
and he's just amazing image full-on fan
service oh my gosh
yeah dress if he wins I think that the
dark ending that they that's more
conceivable to me is that Cersei holds
on to the throne holds on to the power
stabs everyone in the back after they
deal with the existential threat and
then gets to kind of write her own
history of how things went down cuz I
think that's a big theme of the show
also is like the legends are written by
the victors and they don't cover all the
crappiness that actually happened so the
bad guys win but then maybe we flash
forward into one of the many spin-offs
that are coming out and it's like the
tale of Cersei the wise that's so dark
necklace and lives for 400 years oh yeah
and then takes it off and is 400 years
old immediately that's that's so dark
that's the darkest timeline I mean yeah
in the fairy watch
in the first episode Robert Baratheon is
like reading some tale and he's talking
about how the legends don't talk about
everyone shits themselves when they die
or there was the whole Aria watching the
plays sequence about the Lannisters and
it was completely from their perspective
and not yeah that's that's that's
require really annoying like
flash-forward like Harry Potter thing
where they're all in bed old make up
don't do that they're not going to
there's no way but that would be the
worst thing is there anyone else that we
haven't mentioned that you just oh you
hope they get like just a nice like bow
tied around like their story yes yeah I
hope bran gets a nice big castle yeah
I'm waiting for the Hound to go after
his brother yeah that needs to happen
needs to happen I'm lowering my
expectations just because we've thought
about this for so long
what scene of two human beings fighting
each other could live up to our to what
we've put in our minds the Hound and
Brienne of Tarth thinking about that for
like eight seasons right I mean they
have to pull it out they'd have to have
a pretty extraordinary dusting and
they're not bad at that way I mean this
happens to be a strength yeah of the
series here's a totally random question
where we're getting close to the end
here but what was the biggest like
punchin that got oh holy [ __ ] moment
you've had over the course of watching
the entire series I'd love to hear from
each of you oh and the problem is
because I've read the book so of course
I was spoiled for right off of it and
such but I will I will still save the
red wedding because when I read it I
threw my book across the room oh it was
it was definitely the moment for me
where I was like no way so I I have to
go with that for sure Roth the the the
red wedding is mm-hmm first of all it
was extraordinarily executed but for me
of the pinnacle sequences in the show
was the blowing up the cept I thought
just the entire sequence was so
beautifully and elegantly done and just
the look on her face and the pure sight
at the Menace but also you could
understand why she she didn't do the
right thing but the sequence was so good
the three heartbreaking moments though
for me it was Lady I know I'm I just
says so many things about me lady the
baby when they were going after the
Baratheon bastards and having to chain
her dragons yes make me cry every time
which is crazy bail or moment when that
scene was kind of over and Tommen had
you know taken the plunge into the deep
blue yonder
like we took a break my group watching
just went okay we're gonna go get
another drink and let's meet back in
five because I we need to process what
just happened yeah that was craziness
yeah I guess similarly cuz I flew
through the book so I wasn't spoiled or
I would I was spoiled for everything up
until season five or whatever it was
Hodor it was the fact that that had been
don't even a twist but just something
that they had planted there that I
wasn't even looking for I don't think
anyone was looking for we all took it
for granted oh he says his name all the
time but that this has been something
that was built into the lore and
actually had like this really tragic
backstory and the consequences of brand
it's only time been interested in brand
the closed loop that broke this poor
kid's mind was like heartbreaking and
just shocking that it had been there in
plain sight the whole time yes well done
yeah the moment bran tells John about
the the aunt banging he can die it's
fine maybe who knows he could be one
that you guys didn't mention and those
were all just shocking and amazing
moments but a moment that sent me into
just like a self reflection for like a
couple weeks was the red Viper of Dorne
's head
oh my gosh that moment and then you
you've each touched on it I just want to
real quick you're in Vegas you're at the
betting window okay what is in that
chair who or what is in that chair come
the credits roll end of the season final
season Michelle I think it's a melted
pile of slag
I think the Dragons melt it down and
there is no chair Wow okay yeah agreed
no one no one no one hmm faceless men
I'll take Cersei but it's just you know
the Seven Kingdoms become the Seven
Kingdoms again like she's ruling over
basically nothing but she's still
sitting in it gotcha
Wow well we are going to find out well
there's only one way we're gonna find
out by watching the Thrones and these
guys are the hosts of watching Thrones
and they're gonna be breaking it down
every Monday at 11:00 a.m. what happened
the night before and you can catch it on
fandom entertainment what's fandom
entertainment you ask well our sister
channel screen junkies news has a cool
new name its fandom Entertainment and
you can see all the great content you
love right there and watching Thrones is
included with that Roth there's also
gonna be a lot of interactive stuff
going on with fandom right yeah yes if
you can go to fandom the Bema thrones
wiki and then hit the discussion tab and
you can leave your own fan theory you
can comment on fan theories you can make
a poll you can vote on our polls we're
gonna be pulling from that each week and
using that in the watching thrown joke
that's not all we'll be doing what we're
talking about the episode but we're
gonna create a little maesters corner
for michelle from what people are
searching on the wiki's we're gonna talk
about a weekly death pool and fan
theories and things like that but you
can also go participate yourself on the
on the site is there going to be like a
baking contest or someone can do their
best hot pie and like make some bread
we're gonna make a pigeon pie right here
and your hot eyes we're gonna ride on
the air grabbing the butter before you
bake the bread is our solution yeah
nicely done yes that's a secret you guys
there is so much gameofthrones knowledge
right here I am overwhelmed I'm so
excited I hope it's an exciting season I
hope it doesn't rip our hearts out but I
you know probably thank you so much for
taking the time to break down your
thoughts and thank you for checking this
out don't forget to tune in every Monday
11:00 a.m. Pacific to see what happened
the night before season 8 Game of
Thrones final season winter is here and
we're all here for it thanks for
watching you guys
bye bye
[Music]